how are you i'm good oh sorry i'm just
trying to take your money good job
carrie underwood honey it is good night
to be carrie underwood kane brown
really
bless him
kane i've been your hype girl all night
long don't shake your head at me like
that i'm not gonna interrupt her
i'm doing it right now
bless yeah he missed my high five i've
been going come on kane you can do it
you're almost there you know just to
keep him yeah
yes he's so proud he did such a great
job hosting last minute i know that had
to be
tough right but he rose to the challenge
well carrie tonight was your night honey
two wins an epic performance
i mean
how's it feeling now that you've got the
night behind you and you're taking home
two more trophies um it feels awesome um
it was just a great night all around i
mean obviously the winds
i have the most amazing fans in the
world and i feel like my fans and
jason's fans just like united and just
gave us super powers for the night
but yeah it was just it was such a great
night and watching the performances i
feel like everybody just had fun and
it's just a fun night harry underwood
you had a lot of mike fisher what did
you make of carrie underwood's
performance he's like
i was a little bit nervous i watched
some of the uh when she first started to
do it but
i mean that was crazy tell us about your
bag i feel like everybody wants to know
about it
and a great cheerleader for this one
right here but yeah seeing you do those
acrobats and i don't know if that's
exactly what you call it the aerial work
yeah stereo work i was like carrie is
going full on pink for me right now so
we we have um these incredible
aerialists and dancers in our show in
vegas at reflection and
they were so inspiring and i was like i
wonder if i could do that and i have the
song ghost story and i feel like well if
there's a song to try it on it's this
one so i i worked with our director and
choreographer brenda and
we had a couple
sessions and
i was like hey this i'm not too bad this
might be a new workout for carrie
underwood i think so i think it'd be
great to learn more and incorporate
stuff even just for fun i mean i feel
like you're always late to maine and fit
but has this vegas show like sent your
fitness into like overdrive i mean i
definitely have to be um
at the top of my game to be able to just
do the show
because it's a it's packed
and the song's really hard and the last
run i was like i need to do some more
cardio i've been doing a lot of weights
lately but i need to do some more cardio
yeah but yeah i mean that's part of what
i do i just want to be at my best all
the time
you